We know when we are quantifying difficulty, it must somehow incorporate these two concepts
of total amount or weight of water and the distance we have to lift it and so why don't we start
by thinking about the last unit.
Well, in the last unit, we learned about force and namely force is the cause of acceleration
and we use this equation to describe acceleration.
Well, let's try to analyze this situation using forces.
Well, I have all this water here that I need to give rid of it that I need to pump up.
This water have some mass, which means that I can draw it as a force diagram
and to make things simple, I've represented the waters as a simple block of mass m.
The block has a weight and the ground is supplying some normal force to keep the water up.
We're using forces to analyze this situation and well it seems like total weight of water is taken care of.
We've addressed that concept but we haven't talked about the distance we have to lift this water
which also seems very important in analyzing or quantifying this difficulty of this task.
How much work we're going to have to do.
I've been using this word work kind of colloquially but it has a very precise meaning in physics
and that's one we're going to learn today.
We're also going to learn about energy and what is called the conservation of energy
so even though these terms work and energy are relatively new once.
We can go all the way back to the time of Archimedes to study their origins.